[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les petits amis au soin aux nous
sommes très content de vous revoir
j'espère que vous avez passé de belles
vacances cet été
nous nous avons fait un merveilleux
voyage au bo voyons un peu ce qu'il
faisait chaud pas trop il fait toujours
chaud en afrique nounours mais nous y
avons rencontré de très gentil petit
enfant et oui ce qu il était mignon ce
petit diallo et la petite nahla à
neutrons ils m'ont donné des tas de
belles choses pour nicolas et
pimprenelle je descends les leur portée
oui vas-y vitner faut que je suis
content que je suis content de revoir
mes amis ma petite seul et hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
tu es ce que c'est aujourd'hui nicolas
beau puisque je te le dis regarde juste
une croix où on soit buecher peu
t'attendais tu sais la noce c'est un ami
du dornier
voyons voir où me vous avez très beau me
situe dans ce que tu faisais il fait de
ce soleil en afrique ce que j'ai pu
transpirer fait voir et voir ce que tu
nous a rapporté as oui cette fois ci je
vous ai battus là c'est tout pour vous
c'est diallo et sa petite soeur la la
qui vous envoie tout ça
ce sont des grilles du riz oui une
poupée à une poupée qui qui est tous ces
paquets non il faut les ranger
soigneusement à la cuisine c'est du
manioc et du millet et d'autres bonnes
choses avec lesquelles je vous ferai
bientôt un gâteau formidable le gâteau
de dial ou keller ouy patron j'avais
n'arrive pas trop bien nicolas nous va
se coucher voit la balle prenait lé
piano
voilà voilà mes petits
[Musique]
oh
puisque vous êtes si sage demain on
dansera la danse de diallo avec un ni
deux ni à deux mains fed pour un bonne
nuit nicolas moni pimprenelle tort bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nuit des enfants allez vite vous coucher
et si vous êtes sages
nous reviendrons vous voir tous les
soirs et nounours vous apprendra la
danse de diallo allons en route fidèle
compagnon au lot en route fut elle pas
trop bonne nuit
adobe
[Musique]